this band is called Shiva alternativa
which translates as alternative curve
their cheerful easy going a bit insolent
there a happy band from ascension even
if that sounds like an oxymoron one of
their songs is very sad and serious
though despite the light-hearted images
they sing my town my town you're injured
crippled your eyes are sad my town my
town when will you change
ticklish Bendis
oh she ain't even talking a long name
you are still we want to show that OSH
bien Jim is a very normal town when
normal people live and work bus you it's
not only about the camp it's about
everything else around that's literally
just photographer
munich gonna be she also likes his
hometown the marketplace the old houses
the courtyards even if many buildings
are dilapidated he's also interested in
oceane shims jewish history
Tommy a stubbornness of Oswiecim was
once described by its inhabitants as
Jerusalem the water was for me touch it
was a place where Jewish people felt at
home medic has a small private museum
with items he's collected from the town
such as bottles from jakub harbour felts
liquor factory before the war more than
half the population was Jewish something
that many people now do not know the
town is 800 years old but its history
and traditions have been forgotten
overshadowed by the concentration camp
that the Germans built here we no longer
want to live under the shadow of
auschwitz-birkenau we know that the
history is important for everyone my
museum is about showing something
positive psychology of the barracks on
cafe is located in the house where she
moaned clue girl used to live he is said
to have been the last Jew to have lived
in ossian Jim young people say it's hard
to live in a small town but especially
in this one yes strangely enough people
think the camp was built first and then
the town but it's the exact opposite
people have no idea
this is where the harbor felt factory
used to stand minik says that investors
are put off by the town's reputation
urban planners and architects have been
tasked with developing ideas for she and
Jim which at the moment is a cross
between a town with working people and a
memorial for those who were murdered in
Auschwitz some of the projects proposed
are a park of reconciliation a town of
peace or interconnecting bridges system
thick there an official NH it'll grow
together and there should be unity my
leg with faucets dark chocolate chip
Abbas was a tingling today or cebolla
vich was a prisoner at Auschwitz he's
not interested in the future of our
change him he's made it his life's work
to talk about what happened in the
concentration camp I humor you usually
it's the young residents here should
know what happened in that town when
they should tell other people and say
come to Auschwitz learn from all the
evil that went on there shoo-shoo luck
with ms
in the meantime River alternativa
continues to practice they're releasing
a new CD and this one's not about the
town's crippled nature but sounds
dynamic and optimistic
you